the next comment comes to Joe I'm very
excited he has over 100 friends on
Facebook
[Applause]
hey what's up guys I'm straight now
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just in the back bring away the game
[Applause]
I upgraded novelist radiation dude and
alive
popular
to anime which is unfortunate because
anyone who's actually attractive to me
is pretty into anime I forgot I was
constantly cosplaying I have resting
anime face
Oh
the I am Asian or the nose country of
Chinese I'm from a province in china
called south korea
[Laughter]
did your camera
love being Asian you know it's hard
being an Asian man a gentle woman they
have like there's so much better than
Asian man but back home were throwing
you guys away
[Music]
[Applause]
a gym in Asia we look the same
I get there on a wig it'd be a seven
anyone could [ __ ] white dudes
I didn't want to
I mean really they should whether it's
sexy how do you think they're created me
[ __ ] I'm a crucial part of the sexy
process I'll try this give me if you
have sex with me your children will be
very beautiful after that though there
have to be great engineers and that's
important a lot of people make fun of
Asian people because we dogs which I
understand to be very shocking because
in America dogs are treated like family
members but eh we treat our family
members like family members
this tradition has a cultural thing
instead of buying an animal we welcomed
a baby girl which gets another than the
river my Asian friends make pottery
because I like to eat General Tso's
chicken is it General Tso's chicken just
a shitty Americanized version of
something authentically Asian yeah like
yeah but so am i no I am I'm single I
have yet to meet my soul mate I begin to
think maybe it's her fault she doesn't
get out it seems like a loser
and they're gonna be better
but friends are like Monju to learn how
to talk to women it may be it may be
women she's gonna have a listen
anonymous why don't you hear about the
Federal Reserve
so it
this blog light it was like did you know
that you're gonna like to make a baby's
my vagina is technically a 3d printer
only actually your womb is a 3d printer
your vagina the tray
[Laughter]
little imprints one thing with lots of
errors six nine months to pray and the
whole time is printed is complaining
leave this is saying they're not saying
praise at night
I'm glad with it your birth I feel like
a man gave birth would be like bro I've
been eating so much protein and creatine
during my pregnancy
this baby's like 27 pounds already bro
check out a 6-pack of ultrasound
those games in the first trimester I was
talking to this bro dude it was like I'm
so lucky we're not gay can you imagine
if most of the gender we were attracted
to wasn't attracted to his back and I
was like wow
[Music]
I'm not homophobic I I think you know
homophobia is wrong
thank you brave people they're like it's
Adam and Eve not Adam and Steve but I
don't believe we're not even a good
couple bitter clean because first of all
they disobeyed God and made a fruit they
were spicy which is kind of gay
[Laughter]
and they raised Cain and Abel and Cain
murdered Abel why are you taking
parenting advice from people raised a
murderer
they're laying three other people on
earth Psychopaths that killed a quarter
of the world's population cut the whole
earth you can just move you [ __ ] the
genetic diversity hunger starvation
together
I'm not a Christian I grew up Christian
as an Asian person which is kind of
weird because the people who wrote the
Bible didn't even seem to know that age
existed
they couldn't even drop us a line
screech all about the fireworks really
giving back to the Jews
I am an atheist now because of the
kindergarten and have an internet
connection
[Applause]
and I can be stressful to have an
ideology that can be destroyed by facts
no you're just walking down the street
[Applause]
I tried to you know be a good person and
everything I try not to be a racist I
need people to I just get to know them
first
their skin I think over their souls it's
my love you know I mean I'm a minority
how could I it's impossible for me to
Princeton I don't see breaks I only
smell it
the Polish races but I was on an
airplane once and I saw it dude reading
a book in Arabic which really freaked me
out
lettuce I'll pull the corner of the page
put the book away and I was like
your plans
cold air and structures
racist you know a lot of people are
racist to Asian people which I don't
understand whatever I experienced that
I'm like oh you hate respectful people
who keep to themselves quite an
affordable car
I love the Black Panther movie out the
thousand great movie the gate o'clock
children I hear up they can look up to
and not just someone like Martin Luther
King jr. Malcolm X or Harriet Tubman or
Rosa Parks with their good Marshall or
Jackie Robinson Joe Frazier
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now there's a fake person that dressed
like a cat are they going to come out
the yellow Panda
I love America I don't understand all
the sage in America they say in prison
don't drop the soap
that's all I've been helpful you don't
pick up the soap
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]